[Music]
was there one where you were like oh god
I got to make sure I remember these
lyrics the one we've got coming up in a
few weeks with that Sheeran uh-huh he's
got some quite tricky lyrics indeed he
does James Gordon was put to the test
during Tuesday's carpool karaoke with ed
Sheeran and no surprise here he totally
nailed it sobering up we just sit on the
couch one thing led to another
the pair sang lots of EDS hits thinking
hits by others no no you get it uh and
even told some hilarious stories like
this one about the time Edie and Justin
Bieber went to a dive bar together in
Tokyo oh good we ended up at this golf
course right and he put a golf ball in
his mouth and said go ahead and hit it
out I don't know I was pretty hammered
and I had this driving wedge and I was
like okay okay I went I cracked him
across the face how is his face he was
actually really cool about it amazingly
yeah he was like he was like ah bro ah
and then just carried on we also learned
ed has a pretty impressive hidden talent
stuffing malt balls in his mouth
it's 55 oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]